to avoid the worst effects of climate
change EU leaders have committed to
transforming Europe into a highly
energy-efficient low-carbon economy they
also aim at reducing greenhouse gas
emissions by eighty to ninety five
percent by 2050 compared to 1990 levels
the EU is also at the forefront of
international negotiations of climate
change in Paris this December world
leaders are expected to agree on a new
international climate change deal to be
implemented from 2020 the e u--'s
contribution to the new agreement will
be a binding economy-wide domestic
greenhouse gas emissions reduction
targets of at least forty percent by
2030 compared to 1990 there are big
expectations for piracy be seen as a
milestone in the fight against climate
change and what ministers are now going
to define and to lay down in a document
is what the position is going to be the
renunciation started to say what the EU
is going to push for a up by the EU
wants Paris to deliver an ambitious
international agreement that applies to
all countries and puts the world on
track to keep global warming below two
degrees centigrade